begin tonight overseas with an
escalation in tension in jerusalem
a heavy rocket barrage fired from gaza
into southern israel within the past two
hours
so far being taken out of the skies by
the israeli missile defense system known
as the iron dome attack and
counter-attack between the israelis
and palestinians death tolls rising
tonight foreign correspondent trey
yingst
has been in the middle of the fighting
all day good evening trey
brett good evening those rockets
continue to be fired into southern
israel at this moment
all along the gaza strip overhead we can
hear israeli drones and fighter jets
israel is preparing their retaliation
against the factions there
here's what led up to the events
happening right now
explosions and smoke fill the al-aqsa
mosque
early this morning one of the world's
holiest sites erupted
300 palestinians were injured as israeli
police
stormed the compound they are attacking
human beings they are taking the holy
places
it's against all international human
laws these barbarian
aggressive attacks on our holy places
sheikh omar kaswani said that recent
unrest is directly linked to decisions
by israel to try and evict palestinian
families from their homes
monday marked jerusalem day a national
holiday that commemorates israel taking
over east jerusalem
in 1967. the city was also the first
target for factions inside gaza
who this evening fired six rockets
towards it the barrage was the first of
more than a hundred rockets
fired into israel by hamas and islamic
jihad who say they will support
palestinian resistance
at all costs rocket fire is continuing
from the gaza strip
there's a warning going off right now as
you can hear israel's missile defense
system the iron dome
trying to intercept these rounds being
fired from gaza that's the explosion
right there
that is the difference between life and
death for many of these civilians living
along the border
we're going to move here inside a bomb
shelter you can see
families are just trying to get into
this shelter let us get out of the way
here
this is what southern israel has been
dealing with all night
off in the distance you can hear more
sirens these rounds are coming in
continuously
we will not tolerate harm to our
territory to
our capital to our citizens or to our
soldiers
he who attacks us will pay a heavy price
the words by israeli prime minister
benjamin netanyahu already starting to
ring true
across gaza according to the palestinian
health ministry at least 20 people
are dead from israeli retaliation some
of them are children
how does this all end that's the big
question here tonight
there is a possibility for an
egyptian-led ceasefire negotiation
but that negotiation could take days
brett seen this all before
stay safe out there trey thank you hey
sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else